today we're checking out the brand new
Microsoft Surface in matte black when
they announced this I was I was actually
dancing around my office I probably
should have filmed it because it would
have made a really great YouTube or
Twitter video but it's such a huge fan
of all of the service products I feel
like I say that every single time I box
and open something Microsoft Surface
related but they just look cool they
work and I feel like they just have a
really great integration in just sort of
my workflow yes I know I'm a huge back
then but I also like pcs just like I
also like Android phones like it's just
I like technology in general and what
Microsoft has done with their surface
line is they've really stepped it up a
lot like the look the ease-of-use the
portability everything about it it's
just I'm speechless so this is the
American soft surface pro 6 this is the
8th gen Intel Core i5 processor it has a
256 gigabyte hard drive with 8 gigabytes
of go RAM also got the matte black
stylus I'm trying to open this and show
you the stylus at the same time it's
very bad idea I even changed my Apple
watch band to match not sure if you can
tell if you didn't notice I'm pointing
it out it's like when you get a haircut
and no one notices it's like hey did you
know I got a haircut look at my haircut
look at my Apple watch well look at my
knife they match black and rose gold is
such a great combo together they even
came out with a headset they also have a
new service studio coming out man it is
a time for new tech the holiday season
oh yeah look you
let's look this beautiful beautiful Matt
laughs I mean this sick I'm genuinely
really hyped about this and it's great
because this thing is so light and a lot
of times I use I actually use my surface
a lot for watching workout videos so you
used to use my iPad but it doesn't have
a stand it seems to be a little bit
heavy and I like that just stand up
anywhere I can adjust how it stands up
and it's easy to move I'm just like
grabbing it and I just put it in
different places in my gym here it is
you're freaking beautiful let's tip it
up we've got so every this is the
charging brick yeah there okay nothing
else is in here nothing else is in here
we've got this lovely black tape cover
which is not something that is new
they're just like all of the services
this just pops right on to the bottom
just like so magnetic beautifully let's
turn this thing on
look at this so as a thumbnail Cortado
it was your voice or the keyboard along
the way and if you'd like me to stay
quiet
just select the
I don't want you to say quiet I'm going
to talk to these your keyboard is set to
yes with another keyboard layout No
mission accomplished
luckily all linked up let's open up our
pen next Hey look that's me
Cortana hey permission to use yeah I do
what you want he said to set up love it
just take my life
hey recognize me alright here it is it's
here let's go to our first web site I
wonder what that would be
Oh would it be my youtube channel by any
chance
oh do you need to subscribe maybe in
case you haven't already well I just
wanted to do a little unboxing to show
this to you guys because I know a lot of
you are surface fans and you've heard
time I do surface videos a lot of you
guys I get really excited about it so I
wanted to show this to you and share
with you of the beautiful new matte
black surface now I'm gonna be traveling
a little bit here so I'm gonna take this
with me stylus matches beautiful such a
sturdy hinge that if I want to lay it
down like this all the way like a can I
want to just have it up a little bit I
can
[Music]
well thank you guys for watching my
lovely slow-mo montage here it's time to
end the video but I hope you guys
enjoyed this I cannot wait to play with
this as you can tell I'm in Hawaii right
now and I'm shooting a bunch of fun
videos for you guys here so stay tuned
that if you aren't already subscribed be
sure to hit subscribe hit the bell and I
will see you guys later god this looks
so good I can't believe it
[Music]